au sommet de son règne au 19e siècle
napoléon 1er lance la campagne de russie
le 24 juin 1812 sa volonté attaqué la
russie qui ne respectent pas le blocus
continental destiné à ruiner le royaume
uni le 13 septembre 1812 après plusieurs
batailles les russes battent en retraite
et laissent derrière eux un moscou
volontairement incendié la grande armée
se retrouve vite piégé par l'hiver
ravageur lempire français est affaiblie
et la guerre se termine le 14 décembre
1812 son bilan deux cent mille morts
côté français et trois cent mille morts
côté russe napoléon bonaparte fut
néanmoins pardonner en russie où il
n'est pas vu comme un envahisseur
mais comme un grand homme politique
voire un héros romantique à la fin du
xxème siècle aux yeux des soviétiques
napoléon était un révolutionnaire
précurseur du bolchévisme en russie des
collections lui sont désormais dédiés
dans les musées et ses batailles sont
reproduites par des passionnés lors de
spectacles qui attirent jusqu'à 50000
spectateurs
aujourd'hui encore certains se vantent
d'être un descendant de l'un des 2000
soldats de napoléon rester en russie
après la retraite de la grande armée